welcome to the civilian playing Wow
cosmocrator but like cosmo kramer well
it's from the u.s. to 475 and i never
played the sky pretty sure he doesn't
have so many games played i had ever
played him you get the statistics lined
up here okay and that seemed playing a
classical French okay it's going for
them though Alec coin shop Todd the tech
hmm young I recently and found out while
studying this new book on the French
defense by um our God and illness that
knight c6 is actually a valid line I
never really knew that that this is the
case but they're only registered in my
mind that that it is a play will move
but it didn't really look at it in much
detail or any detail at all so I'm just
trying to make things up as I go along
so what what to do here and now okay
let's let's block it might play a five
year no okay of course one issue is that
i have not played c5 attacking the
center but that's not necessarily a
problem it's a quite often just delayed
let's say Bishop to d7 now they will
open up here and long castles King the
atrox the 895 and so on you have some
ideas and play maybe c5 later
yeah of course I'm not going to Castle
shortens would be suicide suicide
mission k rocketry this is a flexible
move may be intending to switch the rock
over to be three and and somewhere f3
interesting not sure what what it is
doing them okay well now i have a night
c4 and possibly queen bee phone yeah
well at least it it should irritate him
okay where does this have seven hanging
so i don't i don't have any Queen move
okay decide the smooth intends to play
push up to e8 yeah see threatening to
take on c4 and i don't think so after my
pawn we capture i am I have gained them
45 square okay we'll just this one
queen bee for us also possible he had
the main problem here is that I'm about
one minute Donald time the position
seems so playable to me it's not there
it's not like fantastic for liquid so
it's a playable position I will get some
activity with the later c5 with b6
moving the noid c5 it's all right
forfeits duty disconnection oops yeah
well that's unfortunate yeah what is
this sure that you not load that yeah
just half a game yeah well I'm not sure
it always feels a bit silly to have
invested like five minutes of comments
and then not upload it okay it's just a
half a game all night before of course I
need to recapture and the question is
some what is yeah how to how to judge
this position my idea is to finally push
for this and maybe the right moment
activate the bishop is of course the
problem with f7 the structure looks
somewhat better for Whitey's got the
better Bishop from a strategic point of
view but he doesn't have any young
clearcuts breaks at the moment I think
if we place a slow move like that we can
consider to to redeploy the night as
well the computer gives Y term and a GM
and think white is is somewhat better
but it's still an interesting position
yeah what I will upload this may be a
show that night
six is the play will move against this
line however i'm pretty sure that it
didn't play it in the most precise
fashion maybe that's f6 at some point I
don't know alright thanks for watching
it's not a really great game but still
maybe you can get something out of it if
you play the French yeah thanks Santa
I'll be back soon with the new game
hopefully in the complete one